sabemos que si tenemos dos líneas que
son paralelas la línea l y la línea m
paralelas entonces sabemos que si son
cortadas por una transversal está en
rosa una transversal entonces los
ángulos correspondientes que se forman
son iguales este lo nombró x éste lo
nombró y entonces sabemos que si l es
paralela a m
entonces x es igual al miden lo mismo
esos ángulos en este vídeo quiero probar
el recíproco esto es lo que sabemos
sabemos esto de aquí yo quiero probar
que si x es igual a ye entonces
l es paralela a m
podemos partir de cualquier lado si son
paralelas entonces los ángulos
correspondientes son iguales si los
ángulos correspondientes son iguales
entonces las líneas son paralelas y lo
voy a hacer por contradicción pongamos
esto a un lado esta es nuestra meta con
todo esto que ya tenemos voy a asumir
que esto no es verdad entonces lo que
voy a asumir es que x es igual a ye y él
no es paralela a m ahora pensemos en qué
tipo de realidad esto va a crear si
tenemos dos líneas que son distintas y
no son paralelas entonces en algún punto
se van a cortar de acuerdo entonces voy
a dibujar a mis rectas aquí está la
recta l y la recta m corta la recta l
porque no son paralelas entonces por
definición se van a cortar en algún
punto ahora aquí voy a poner esta
transversal
entonces aquí tenemos el respectivo
equis y acá tenemos allí pero es x
entonces esos dos ángulos miden lo mismo
dada entonces esta realidad en
cualquiera de los casos estamos
asumiendo que esta distancia es no nula
aquí hay una distancia por ende acá
también hay una distancia en este
segmento por lo tanto tenemos aquí el
punto a y el punto b estamos diciendo
que la distancia del segmento ave es
mayor que 0 asumiendo eso en cualquier
caso también aquí tenemos que la
distancia del segmento ave es mayor que
0 cuando asumimos que estas dos líneas
se cortan nos estamos formando un lindo
triángulo si lo ven está lindo ajá y
está formado por tres segmentos uno de
ellos ave y aquí nombre a este punto c
entonces el otro segmento bc y el otro
hace
ahora recuerda sabemos mucho acerca de
encontrar los ángulos de un triángulo
entonces podemos aplicar lo que ya
sabemos primeramente este ángulo tenemos
que este ángulo es suplementario con
este de aquí o sea que la suma de ambos
se 180 por lo tanto este de abajo mide
180 menos x y que sabemos sabemos que la
suma de los ángulos internos de un
triángulo es igual a 180 entonces nombró
a este ángulo z y la suma de los tres
ángulos va a ser igual a 180 por lo
tanto pongo aquí lo siguiente
escribo x más 180 menos x más z
es igual a 180 x x se va y puedo restar
a ambos lados 180 entonces tengo que z
es igual a 0
es decir si tenemos a x igual ayer y l
no paralela a m entonces tenemos esta
rara situación donde la intersección de
esas dos rectas forman un ángulo de
medida cero
se está igual a cero grados entonces
tendríamos aquí algo muy raro ni
siquiera se formaría un triángulo
tendríamos que el segmento ave tiene
medida cero entonces tendríamos algo así
como un triángulo degenerado un
triángulo que no se abre es una línea
entonces l&m con la misma recta por lo
tanto no tenemos un triángulo que se
forme esto nos lleva a una contradicción
la contradicción de que el segmento ave
tiene medida cero es como si no
existiera pero eso es una contradicción
porque a ve el segmento ave es mayor que
cero o decir que la recta l y la recta
deben ser la misma ya que la apertura
entre ellas es igual a cero es una
contradicción de ambas formas llegamos a
una contradicción es decir si asumes que
x es igual a ye y él no es paralela a m
esto te lleva a algo que no tiene
sentido en absoluto
esto prueba que si x es igual ayer
entonces l es paralela a m porque
demostramos que si x es igual ayer no
hay manera de que l y m sean líneas
distintas y sean no paralelas quedó
probado entonces si l y m son paralelas
los ángulos correspondientes son iguales
y si los ángulos correspondientes son
iguales lm son paralelas